process here
because you bring out the bishop like
this uh it can become very vulnerable
right away so i'm not sure that i like
the like the variational approach here
no please don't and it's too soon
it's too soon hikaru we didn't even
reach a climax
i do check is coming and what's 92 chips
oh
what's going on here 92 c2
and cars oh no we're nice to see one
take out f3
take it off three oh my god you have to
take on f3 dude
bishop d3 a brilliant pre-move not a
pre-move he stopped the pre-move
that is hikaru nakamura showing off his
bullet skills
magazine's down to five seconds he's
gonna move quickly
gosh i've never seen magnus play a move
like that
like ever oh my goodness
he was winning that game and he gives it
away
gosh really my queen d6 checker
[Laughter]
wait bishop f5 so i can tip and i fly
with my knife amazing cash oh my god
five is incredible the thing went oh my
he played it oh my gosh
unbelievable that is the move of the day
that is
incredible and knight h1 rook takes h1
oh my gosh this is mate everywhere gotta
made him now
don't botch the king g4 queen g3 okay
okay there's no immediate made by taking
on g2 should be good enough or h5
check 92 92 take the queen and run oh
my god model attack worthy of
i know the computer says equal but i
have no idea what to play here with
black
what a freaking move here comes queen of
six oh
always sacks
[Music]
the bishop c5 check coming is that the
idea
that was set if king ji won bishop c5
and if the king runs out here comes now
black is winning oh my gosh
we shake [ __ ] holy bleep
i don't know if he knows three move
repetition if black plays king c7 it's a
draw
oh no don't play king c7 please oh
my repetition what
can we see but wow it's
connor it's feeling oh my god what
how is that a draw by repetition
[Music]
oh my god look who came in this room
oh my
the question is does hafu take the grand
master approach here
and just take the perpetual for the
championship
this is
a good old-fashioned soviet grandmaster
would just would just
doesn't matter we gotta listen and she's
about to deliver the goods
i just said it
[Music]
yeah i kind of like hiding on h7 and
maybe she's going to do that now yeah
that's a nice little hiding spot and now
rook v8
um and queen and me
oh my gosh that is the swindle of the
century
wow i did it i did it i oh my god i said
king h7 i love this hiding spot
oh my gosh what did i do
that is absolutely devastating
here comes queen e7 of course if i
predicted
nope no hikara wants more i was going to
say if i predicted a decisive result
we'd get a perpetual draw
curse bishop bishop oh
gladys love our champion versus someone
we think materials on because we don't
think maxime
has enough to get a win here which would
force a bullet tiebreaker
unfortunately for mvl he missed his
chances earlier in the same game but i
don't think they're coming back
okay bringing the king of the board this
is nice remember the id so there was a
trick there if queen f7 the move was
queen he said oh he misses kinky seven
oh he doesn't maxime tricks him
oh and hike freaks out
oh my god maxime tricked him
holy crap
oh my god here comes everyone yelling at
dan dan jinxed it
it's not my fault he blundered the queen
ending i'm just one man
oh my freaking god no resignation for
you vivid
okay no resignation coming your way
why would you not do that well because
you want to waste some i think if your
air grows and you really do want to
waste time off the match clock oh my
gosh stalemate
that's why you don't resign that was
still me
oh my gosh rook seat in brook 64 the b5
we see
the drama is real this is that he's got
10 seconds to get one puzzle right and
he goes to the corner queen
one queen b one queen f1 queen oh no he
missed it for two seconds who takes v8
defeat broke
oh my gosh the time ticks away
oh look at him he goes nuts
and hans neiman is going nuts that was
crazy
that was absolutely bonkers i cannot
believe that just happened
that was crazy
oh my gosh there's mate open
knight b4 this is amazing oh my gosh
united 192 mate
knight f192 mate oh my god oh this is
incredible
how oh my
that ness was that
exclamation mark on top i'm pulling up
that board
that is what is that that was sick
i know it's bad what what what did
hikaru say about this move you say
he would not be happy yeah what is danny
doing
danny what are you doing
danny i mean i know danny is bad but
danny what are you doing
this is why people want no chat no chat
no chat
no chat hans is a good player danny is
bad no no chad
no chat chad don't make jokes about then
know that no no chad
please stop chat no
okay chad i get it i get it what's
happening
somebody help me out the queen is coming
to g4 but is there a mate
there's no meat there's bishops
oh my gosh what's happening queen h2 and
they take on f4 we check
or this oh my gosh we might just see a
repetition
what in the world have we seen here now
what is working shoot she may forget she
wants you blundered
oh my gosh she remember gets one check
and even that didn't work because the
queen would have taken
but it looks like all is said and done
crazy
game and what a crazy match this is a
very sad story for executives oh
no oh my god
[Applause]
there's no way and
and tactics that occur in the middle
game but this is kind of on cue because
normally the tactics you get you should
also be familiar with if you're getting
pawn structures you know
clearly nepal was not familiar with this
opening
and i want to say i called it robert i
said what did i say team india needed to
turn it around they needed to be led by
their co-captain co-board and he's about
to deliver mate and four
what in the world i mean i'm looking at
this and i'm speechless for pretty much
the first time ever
queen h6 is the threat with queen g7
mate to follow
and there's no way to stop it well you
could play king of cheat right but then
the problem is after queen h6 rook g8
stopping me on g7
it can't stop made on h7 after that so
this is a forced checkmate and vichy
i mean putting in the the psychological
work of what might yon the punjabi not
be comfortable with today
and he gets the victory that quickly you
do not see that kind of miniature
against yonder palmer she pretty much
[Music]
bye